Happy Thanksgiving everyone we hope you
are gobbling up lots of delicious food
with family and friends this turkey day
get ready for a fun-filled show ahead
we're answering your fan mail questions
for the entire hour so let's hit it all
right here's a Facebook question from
Harley F and I'll start with you Tyrus
do you dress up for Thanksgiving dinner
or do you dress down and stay in your
comfy clothes I I wear the required uh
outfit for overeating so I've I've fast
I work hard and I only have one rule on
Thanksgiving it's my day so my outfit is
comfortable sweats probably a cut off
shirt no just to be able to lay a pocket
from my remote between naps no one
changes the channel and I'm ready to go
so like yeah you don't dress up you
never dress up yeah necktie things with
buttons are gonna pop yeah do you wear
that chain uh no no nothing that's going
to constrict the eating yeah let me ask
you a question Tyrus what do you do with
that chain when you're at home I hang it
up I put it up yeah you have a gun right
next to it no well I got two next one
they're always loaded okay all right so
am I asking the same question okay okay
where did you dress up well it kind of
depends uh yeah a little bit I try to
make an effort but I do like the elastic
pant situation that's a good idea that's
a great idea how about you Jesse jacket
and tie for you yes we're more formal at
the waters household so maybe not a tie
we do Ties on Christmas but for
Thanksgiving we'll do a Blazer really
yes with shorts or with slacks with
maybe some cords or some flannels very
nice I see I see the plants how about
you Jessica
I'd say it dressed up a bit but I love
how now jeans have stretch built into
them yes so it's like perfect for
holidays they can look like cute with
like a nice top or a nice sweater but
okay the key is you can't wear like I
can't wear socks and boots on
Thanksgiving or inside because
everybody's house is always too hot
so you have to wear no socks yeah and
then like a a see or we dress down like
me and never get invited anywhere oh
that's not true I do it on purpose
because I'm I'm home yeah it's my house
my rules my turkey all right second
question this is from Barbara B what is
Trend traditional Thanksgiving food that
you can't stand
uh traditionally Anything Green that's
not the day it's not your day but you're
a health freak you you not on
Thanksgiving not on Thanksgiving bets
are off yeah okay I am best described as
fat tacular on Thanksgiving right it is
it's a car party
all right you've seen Ghostbusters watch
Slimer oh yeah that's me all right
traditional food you don't like Dan well
I don't like brussels sprouts I feel
like anyone who makes a Brussels sprout
my husband loves brussels sprouts he
loves them and and cooked anyway I feel
like if I try to eat one piece of
Brussels sprout it takes half an hour to
chew it I really don't like it yeah yeah
how about you Jesse I used to hate the
cranberry sauce and then I was converted
to Pro cranberry sauce so now because
you and I would have a problem that's my
favorite thing yeah that's okay if I
didn't like it more for you like cheap
cranberry sauce for the fancy no in the
can I think that's delicious and I hate
fancy I just don't like fancy
Thanksgiving food actually I think
things should be like you know the cream
of soup
mushroom soup on top of the green beans
like and the fried onion like my sister
I love all that stuff you know what I
add to the cranberry sauce I put like
hot spices in it so it's kind of spicy
you can put orange rinds in the ground
they're not spicy yeah it's delicious
what kind of spot like what do you mean
um like you can put a little um like a
Chipotle uh like a hot yeah and and puts
orange rinds in it and it's kind of
sweet and sound like leaning forward
while she's talking but yeah tell me
more okay yeah all right so Instagram
question from T Jerome 1994. what's the
proper time Tyrese the Thanksgiving meal
12 o'clock start the party at 12
kickoffs at one you eat your lunch
watch the game take a nap you read again
at three watch the later game take a nap
and then at seven you come back you eat
again and then you watch a recap yeah
but is a turkey done by noon time I
start the turkey the day before I'm I I
cook my turkey so I started the day
before you fry it no I I don't like the
frying I like traditional in the oven
and I see a little thing pop up it's
time to go to work so got it you can
keep checking it and graving and all the
stuff can't do that in the fryer yeah I
think between two and five
okay yeah how about you Jesse I'll do
six or seven but I feel like I'm in the
minority I feel like everybody else eats
early but I need to get my drink on and
wait a minute you have festivities you
have like big family gatherings right so
everyone gets together yeah so they're
drinking for five hours before dinner
three to four
how about you Jessica like three four
o'clock we do Bagels in the morning so
that's kind of like at about 11 while
stuff is being prepared and then three
four o'clock and then you can hang out
and then there's room nine o'clock when
everyone's going to sleep then you have
your last burst of whatever thing you
want to keep eating all right but six
seven is very strange it's like a normal
dinner yeah it's like a normal I feel
like he has a large family gathering and
it takes everyone time to get there
okay guys Facebook question from Tracy G
on Thanksgiving do you cook two dishes
or just watch sports
I like I said I'm in charge of the
turkey everything else belongs to other
people but I'm I have to be constantly
watched because I'm quick to try to
steal I'm banned from the kitchen other
than turkey dude because all right how
about you Dana Cooks nobody wants me
cooking but for sure but I'll do dishes
for sure I'll do dishes okay and I love
to watch sports oh dishes oh I'm sorry I
misheard the question no that's racist
you want me to wash all the white dishes
it works in my house all right Jesse
I'll offer to help with the dishes oh
right that's yeah I just mean it yeah
politely yeah okay but um do you just
watch sports I do I watch football and I
don't cook okay Jessica uh I'll do
dishes and we don't really like in my
house growing up we didn't have sports
on never a TV even in the living room or
dining room my husband's family though
has it on and it feels much more
traditional that way so I like doing I
like doing it sometimes I'll clear my
place you'll dump them in the sink for
other people oh I'll bring it to the
sink I will clean my plate in front of
me but that's where it stops all right
Tyrus what's oh this is from Gladys T
Hill at Gladys Hill what's one food your
family makes that other families don't
make
we make uh our sweet potato casserole
East Coast style so a lot of my
influences my grandmother was from the
East Coast from Lynn Massachusetts so
like her macaroni and her sweet potato
casserole is lights out and then South
they do things differently and I refuse
like no it has to be like the way
grandma made it and I won't eat it like
don't put no extra stuff it's straight
up East Coast all right potatoes Dana I
really wish I could give you an answer
here but there's just no other food I
don't know I don't know but I don't even
know what it would be okay so okay nope
not nobody wants my queso either that
broke the internet you should be proud
of that queso all right Jesse what's
wonderful your family eats another
family stuff well my mom cooks these
creamed onions
we don't eat it but she cooks it
is popular throw down I'm going to bed
she can throw down I like those I'll
come uh Fried Chicken somebody make
fried chicken
Thanksgiving Christmas all that my dad
was really great and I did like an olive
oil fried chicken I sound like I'm about
to start crying which I'm not I'm sad
that he's dead but I have something in
my throat but Fried Chicken okay
this has to be fast uh this is from path
in the yard at path in the yard describe
the first meal you hosted and make it
fast uh me and my homies uh in college
and everybody brought something and
nothing matched Dana the first we did
invite one year Peter and I invited all
sorts of the White House staff orphans
that didn't have time to be able to go
home yeah I don't even remember that
meal exactly but I do remember Genie
Momo and her sister Lisa came and it was
a lot of fun Jesse I don't think I've
ever personally hosted Thanksgiving but
that's that's going to change yeah
really why is that going to change well
we're gonna we're gonna host we're gonna
Step It Up You're Gonna step it up okay
Jessie Jessie I've never me personally
never hosted a Thanksgiving all right
well I wish I could have answered them
too but I didn't have time I want to
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now